[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily the trial of a
former dallas police officer
accused of murdering a man in his own
apartment killing this man
was unnecessary and it was unreasonable
hear from the defendant herself as amber
geiger says she had to shoot
i asked god for forgiveness epic hate
myself
and remembering the life of both of john
master the tempest is raising
the bills that's next on lawn crime
daily
[Music]
welcome everyone i'm brian buckmart
along with terry austin
we're giving you an inside look at the
murder trial of amber geiger
a dallas police officer who shot and
killed botham jean
an innocent victim sitting in his
apartment when geiger
entered and pulled the trigger she
thought she was returning to her own
apartment
she was really entering his and she was
on the wrong floor
of the apartment complex where they both
lived
the shooting happened as geiger was
returning home from work
long crime dailies and jeannette levy
has more on how the shooting unfolded
amber geiger was not wearing a body
camera but the responding officers were
and their cameras captured the aftermath
of the shooting
the video starts in the parking garage
at the apartment complex where amber
geiger
and botham john lived officers struggled
to enter
defendant amber geiger gave 911
dispatchers the code to enter the gate
then the frantic officers run up the
stairs
trying to reach the fourth floor where
the shooting occurred
they arrive then snake through the
labyrinth-like corridors to botham
john's apartment
the defendant's voice attracted their
attention
inside a shaken defendant said she
thought she was in her own apartment
when she pulled the trigger
geiger said she shot both him john in
the top left
she shot twice but only struck him once
[Applause]
then the first responders tried in vain
to save john's life
john died at the hospital this is
angenette levy
for law and crime daily
thanks angenet here to break down the
state's version of events is law and
crime daily's terry austin
thanks brian prosecutors say baltham
john was simply at home eating a bowl of
vanilla ice cream when an intruder burst
through his front door
as john was trying to get off the couch
to figure out
who was coming into his home amber
geiger raised her gun
and aimed directly at her target geiger
shot john
twice opportunity for de-escalation
no opportunity for him to surrender
bang bang rapid double tap while she's
on the phone with 9-1-1
while she's in the room alone with both
of them she decides to send text
messages to her partner
she doesn't one time say he was coming
at me
she does a one-time say he had a weapon
she doesn't one time say he was scaring
me he made me fear for my life
none of that and that's when she would
have said it
the reason is because it didn't happen
she shot beau
because she thought he was in her
apartment and that's it
that was the prosecutor's version of
events but geiger's attorneys argued
that the state's case was about a rush
to judgment
they asked the jury to listen carefully
to the facts of the case and they place
blame on the apartment complex
for being confusing
amber geiger firmly and reasonably
believed that she was in her own
apartment
amber geiger firmly and recently
believed
that she confronted an intruder in her
apartment
amber geiger firmly and reasonably
believed that she had no choice
that she had no options but to use
her gun to keep all from
from dying that was her firm
and reasonable belief 92 people
reported that lived in south side flats
reported walking unintentionally walking
to the wrong apartment
on the wrong floor 71 of those that
lived on the third and fourth floor
because the higher you go the more
confusing it is
additionally 46 tenants had gone to the
wrong apartment
just like we learned that amber geiger
has and placed their key
in the door a witness who lived in the
apartment complex said he might have
heard
two people talking just before gunfire
rang out
what i would describe was two people
meeting each other on a surprise so
i'm assuming you know the doors open and
two people meet and then i had two
gunshots go off
okay so let's stop there for a second
you said when you get to the conjunction
between
the two hallways you hear what sounds
like two people meeting vasa parks
is that a yes yes ma'am was it two
separate voices
could you tell if one of the voices was
giving loud commands
like stop police or anything of that
nature
yeah but no it wasn't that wasn't what
they were saying
that's not what you heard no okay um
however you say you didn't hear exactly
what you heard no i can't i can't say i
heard any
any any type of words that i can make
out
once you in that conjunction between the
two hallways
and hear the voices and the pop how soon
after the voices did you hear the sounds
of gunshots
right after right after it was quick
quick
and the two gunshots you heard were they
quick
joining me now is retired new york
police detective turned professor
kirk burkhalter along with terry austin
kirk let's start with you
as a former detective can you tell us
what went wrong here
well brian two concepts i will uh start
with
one is cover and concealment and the
other is trying to obtain a tactical
advantage
so first covering concealment this is a
concept where
put something physical between you and
your adversary
it could be something physical or
distance both work uh equally as well
and if you have an opportunity unless
the threat is real and macgyver
amber geiger never testified that she
saw a
weapon two is uh tactical advantage so
if you're standing face to face with
your adversary neither party necessarily
have an advantage
so you certainly by backing out of the
door putting
distance between your adversary and
yourself or that wall
and then also gaining a tactical
advantage so you can identify your
target
and here she just fired and it may sound
like a monday
morning quarterbacking but i'm really
not because the purpose of police
training law enforcement training
is so that police officers will act
reflexively
in a combat situation which is what she
thought she was in
so that would be my critique
all right so let's let's see what else
we've got here when you're thinking
about the geiger case because of course
that could have been something
uh that amber guy could have done but
still ahead on law and crime daily
defendant amber geiger testifies in her
own defense her words under oath
right after this break
[Music]
former dallas police officer amber
geiger took the stand in her own defense
and when asked about the shooting and
killing a man in her
own apartment she broke down and forced
the proceedings to a halt
geiger is the dallas police officer
accused of shooting and killing botham
jean
geiger was sexting a co-worker when she
went inside the wrong apartment thinking
it was her own
she says she approached the apartment
door noticed it was slightly open
and tried to use her electronic key fob
to go inside
she describes hearing someone inside and
being scared
in the middle towards the windows when i
saw the silhouette fever standing back
there
i used my left arm to fully open it
and at that time that's whenever i'm
drawing my service weapon out
and i yelled at him it's like let me see
your hands let me see your hands
he started coming towards me how fast
was he coming towards you
a fast-paced walk wasn't running wasn't
running when you saw him coming towards
you what was going through your mind
i thought he was coming back i couldn't
see his hands he was gonna kill me
did you hear anything as he was walking
towards you
he there was a loud yell he was yelling
hey hey
hey an aggressive voice and that's at
that point whenever
i shot somewhere in this area yes
when you shot what happened
on cross the prosecutor demanded to know
why geiger was sexting her partner
on the police force instead of helping
botham john
you must have stopped completely giving
him cpr when you sent a message to mark
rivera
saying i need to hurry right i did text
him that
okay and so you must have at that point
stop cpr entirely yes i did
and then not even a minute later you
must have stopped cpr entirely again
to send a second message to martin
rivera
i was already out in the hallway oh so
you had already left him
that's whenever they told me to leave
the officers so that's
no ma'am i'm talking about at 10 03 p.m
uh mr lee officer lee and officer blair
didn't arrive until almost 100
yes i do remember that like whenever
they showed me i sent those text
messages
you texted mr rivera using your hands
yes i did and as you were doing that you
were unable to give mr john your full
attention
the attention that he deserved yes i did
and then you made the choice to do that
a second time
isn't that true yes sir all right so at
both of those times
you put your needs and your wants over
heads
i still cared about him did you put your
needs and your wants over him when you
decided to do that
no sir back with me to break down amber
geiger's testimony is terry austin and
kirk burkhalter terry
this sexting argument that came up
during cross-examination
seems to be a big point do you think it
could sway the jury and why
i definitely think it could sway the
jury it was introduced to demonstrate
her state of mind you know before the
event she was thinking about other
things
during the event she was thinking about
other things she wasn't trying to save
him
and i do think they will use it against
her and
even more frankly it's an insinuation
right or wrong that she's having an
affair so i think the jury's going to
think about that
kirk i get she's off duty but she was
still trained as an officer what
response
do you think she should have given after
this accidental shooting as she
describes it
so what's important to keep in mind is
that a police officer has a
responsibility to render aid to a person
that they just shot
as the same as if they came across that
person in the street
so she certainly had a responsibility to
to render the same amount of aid and i
think the jury will certainly take that
into account it could be indicia
of some form of her intent to actually
kill fathom john yeah i mean maybe it's
a lack of mistake maybe it's just a bad
officer
depending on how the jury is going to
look at this it's not just the act
itself the shooting and going into the
wrong apartment
but the question is going to become what
about after the shooting what did she do
and it'd definitely be used against her
but when we return a look at the life of
both and john
through videos and music archived by his
university
[Music]
police shooting victim both um jean left
quite a legacy
and he was in fact an accomplished
singer thanks to the archives of his
alma mater
we are able to introduce you to him
through both pictures
and in music long crimes aaron keller
has gene's
story
hi i'm both amjah and i am a senior
accounting and management information
systems major and i am from the island
of saint lucia
that is the voice and this is the face
of the man whose life ended
with the pull of a trigger in dallas
chaos surrounded both of jean's final
moments but friends and family remember
other things a bright smile and
uplifting music
at harding university a christian
college in arkansas let's praise god
this morning john was an active singer
[Music]
in the trial of his shooter botham
jean's sister described him from the
witness stand
as his portrait sat nearby when he
started high school he started a choir
at the high school he also started song
leading at
our church church of christ and he fell
in love with music
he even wrote songs church songs
mourners who attended john's funeral
wore red his
favorite color he was very active in his
community in his hometown
in st lucia in terms of serving the
youth and in terms of just doing a lot
of community service
attorney suanne robinson is of counsel
to a law firm which represents
sean's relatives the family does
definitely
want amber geiger brought to justice for
what she did i think the outcome is
going to be a conviction on murder
that is the outcome that they're looking
for yes there is evidence both of john
was not perfect he used marijuana to
treat adhd
when that became public critics lashed
out at those who thought it disparaged
him
and back at harding john leaves a legacy
am strong the university and his family
cherish the music we found four songs
that he wrote
um all about christ and wanting to get
to heaven
it's not just notes and words a planned
50 thousand dollar scholarship in john's
honor
swelled to more than half a million
dollars with support from his employer
the family has chosen to deal with it
by celebrating his life as opposed to
focusing on his
how his life has ended
[Music]
a life ended with tragedy a legacy of
hope
[Music]
[Applause]
this is aaron keller for the law and
crime network
[Music]
thank you for the update aaron
definitely a light that left us too soon
and when we come back the verdict for
amber geiger and the
extraordinary reaction from the family
of both jean
[Music]
we the jury unanimously find the
defendant amber geiger
guilty of murder as charged in the
indictment
no outburst
that was the jury's verdict after about
five hours of deliberating
the next question the penalty under
texas law a murder conviction can carry
a 5
to 99 year sentence geiger ultimately
received a 10-year sentence but her
sentencing hearing was anything but
ordinary
peace during a victim impact statement
the brother of murder victim botham jean
asked if he could give amber geiger a
hug and so
after receiving permission he did
the image of the man who lost a brother
forgiving the woman who pulled the
trigger
even telling her that he loved her led
to a massive social media response
about the role of forgiveness in the
criminal justice system
the judge cried on the bench during the
embrace
afterwards cameras showed the judge
hugging the victim's family
and finally the judge retrieved her
personal copy of the bible
and told geiger that it was her job to
read it starting with john 3 16.
the judge read the passage to the
defendant convicted of murder
and even gave her a hug then deputies
led amber geiger
off to prison botham jean's mother spoke
after the sentencing hearing calling for
reforms in both state and local police
forces
his privacy was violated amen
she intruded on him yes she did
and that was not enough she killed him
our life must move on but our life
must move on with change
there's got to be a better day
and that better day starts with each and
every one of us
right the city of dallas needs to clean
up inside
amen the dallas police department
has a lot of laundry
the texas rangers
need to know who's on board yes
and every single one of you citizens of
dallas and residents of dallas
need to know what to do to get your city
right that's right
thank you thank you
after the conclusion of the jury trial
one of the key witnesses was himself
shot and killed and what authorities say
was a crime completely unrelated to his
testimony
joshua brown who lived across the hall
from both himsean
was gunned down in what authorities
describe as a robbery gone bad
three people are facing trial in that
shooting
amber geiger remains in prison but has
appealed her conviction
her attorneys say that because she was
mistaken about
where she was she cannot be convicted of
murder they're asking an appeals court
to throw out geiger's conviction
or can victor have a lesser charge
criminally negligent homicide
and to hold a new sentencing hearing
botham john's family has filed civil
lawsuits against the apartment complex
where the shooting happened
and against the maker of the locks on
the doors which were allegedly defective
the family also sued the city of dallas
and amber geiger personally
a federal judge dropped the city as a
defendant saying there were no grounds
for municipal liability
terry let's bring you back in along with
kirk there
there have been a number of unarmed
black men killed throughout the years
some of which have forever changed
change sorry the criminal justice system
do you see the arrest trial and
conviction of amber geiger as one of
those cases that changed the system
here's what i think brian i think there
are many people who are unhappy with the
fact that she only got
10 years yes she was convicted of murder
but she only got 10 years and then there
are others who think that this was just
a tragic
accident what i will say that impressed
me overall with this particular
conviction was the fact that the family
the brother in particular
embraced amber geiger and even the judge
so i think that left a huge impression
upon people who watch this trial kirk
same question does this conviction
change the system um i
i'm not sure about that because when we
think a lot about the the violence
against black men and women
we think about it at the hands of law
enforcement and while
amber geiger is employed as a police
officer she was off duty
at the time this occurred so she was not
in the performance of her official
duties um so it's very different than
what we've seen permutating uh this
country in the form of videos and
stories and so forth and certainly we
have other folks
that have committed these heinous acts
but the focus is really on law
enforcement
so i'm not sure how much this has moved
the needle forward
uh given that this is such an extreme
case thank you kirk thank you terry and
thank you for joining us here at law and
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you